okay so this is my spoiler review of the
new Hulu series catch-22 if you haven't
watched yet watch my spoiler free review
first and then come back to this after
you have seen it now I had really low
expectations for the show yes it's a
George Clooney project which is exciting
but my cup of tea is usually not war
stuff and also not a big fan of satire
but this one meet over this was a
pleasant surprise for me breaking this
down I think I don't know how anyone
watching this could think that that was
a bad acting performance Christopher
Abbott was amazing as the lead here is
yo-yo I thought he hit every note to a
tee and I loved watch him on the screen
I couldn't keep my eyes off of him like
he was so likable in a way too and he
it's a complicated character to play and
I thought he just killed it knowing that
you know these big stars around you and
they have minor roles and you're kind of
asked to carry the load he did one hell
of a job and that's clear why I got this
part I wonder if you'd recognize him
from the sinner he was Jessica Biel's
boyfriend in that so it was cool to see
him actually show his acting chops it's
a welcome addition to a huge roster of
great actors in the game right now and
he's definitely gonna go near the top
for me this performance was awesome I
stand out scenes I really thought was
humor wise had to be in that final
episode when he's walking around in
Italy and his balls got all messed up oh
my god when he was walking like that old
man I could not stop laughing that was
hysterical and they were they blended
this just heavy themes and so dark but
they blended so well with humor and it
really worked and they didn't hold onto
that crutch that annoys me of like oh
let's just do a humor about George
Clooney dancing and it's funny cuz it's
George Clooney they didn't fall into
that trap which I was afraid of so I
really appreciate that Kyle Chandler
great as usual
I wish who Lowry was used a little more
here that was little disappointing he
was very light in a role it could have
actually just been anyone who played him
I don't think they used his best stuff
but it was good to see him on screen
and man that actor of Milo was really
good and Milo such an interesting
character and and how this show just
shows you so much themes and Milo being
this just epitome of greed and the
American Dream and his bad size it's
good side where he's just this big
dreamer and he's getting all these crops
and he's just a businessman at heart but
it's also just bad I mean he's doing a
lot of messed-up stuff and Kyle chairs
characters aboard the - so you're seeing
all these guys are putting their necks
out on the line bombing stuff and
they're just making business and profits
out of it it's such a smart story I
never actually read the book I want to
now that's how much I like to show me
want to read it and I understand why
they would want to make a show on this
it's very powerful I mean the way they
did it they killed significant
characters and his friends but it wasn't
overdone somehow even they did a lot and
every time he felt it I even felt when
the new kid died and that's really hard
to pull off because you're just meeting
a person and they made you feel so many
emotions and even just a stuff in Italy
with the woman and how that guy ended up
turning
raping this girl and killing her and
that was for shot with him talking about
his college days and they really let a
lot of things pay off here which was
nice and when he's walking around knew
it was just wow it's just so much about
humanity and just him being basically a
man now and not wearing the uniform and
going to these standards because he
really deep down doesn't believe in it
and it's just all about the catch-22
line you know and they presented well
the doctor saying in the beginning how
basically if you want to leave then they
know you're not insane and you're trying
to be crazy and that's the reason but if
you're saying that you're totally saying
you got to stay that's the whole
catch-22 of it and they made sure that
theme was strongest and it worked and
they made this not feel repetitive it
was smart they only did six episodes or
something like this they got the point
clearly and it wasn't beaten over it was
always something you were interested in
to see what would happen
it was exciting it was funny you know I
think my one of my few complaints was
just that it did feel like a show though
her episode one was great and then the
odd number
episode three was great but two and four
like ends a little slow couldn't move a
little quicker but
overall it was really really good and I
just think that it was such a effort put
into this which is really rare with so
many shows rushing to get things out now
and so much content and this is another
hit for Hulu I definitely think having
them always crutched onto Handmaid's
Tale this is something that can go in
the category of like oh no I think a lot
of people talk about this and this would
be very popular because it feels like a
rare taste of almost when like 90s TV
was really good in that sense it felt
like that it just had that heart to it I
guess and you just learned a lot I just
think it's one of those shows you can
throw on with your family and you are
gonna you all will have something from
it you're all gonna like it and what a
way to just make you really think about
war and so many shows and movies will
hit these themes about war but this
still felt fresh and it I mean took a
very popular novel and I think if you've
read the book you had to have like this
right I mean please let me know I
haven't read it and let me know if those
people are satisfied with this cuz as a
show I thought it was excellent and the
cinematography was just beautiful the
setting was great and I bought all of it
I was never like all this actors
screwing the scene up or it was everyone
was putting in their 110 percent so I'm
happy this turned out great
so I am gonna give this one a 9.1 let me
know you thought of it down below I'd
love to hear your thoughts I read every
comment try to respond as many as I can
please follow me at Steve rd1 on Twitter
and Instagram for more than me and
please make sure to subscribe I review a
bunch of TV shows I do movies I also do
celebrity interviews I have one with
Craig Ferguson I just did so make sure
to check that out and I'll see you next
time